the nominees for Best Motion Picture are
the Curious Case of Benjamin Button
Kathleen Kennedy Frank Marshall and Seon
Chafin producers frost/nixon Brian
Grazer Ron Howard and Eric Felner
producers milk dan jinx and Bruce Cohen
producers the reader Anthony Minghella
Sydney [ __ ] Donna Jia T and Redman
Morris producers Slumdog Millionaire
Christian Coulson producer the Oscar
goes to Slumdog Millionaire
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much to the Academy as as
you can see our film was a collaboration
between hundreds of people and I'm so
happy that so many of them could be with
us here tonight to share this moment
together we've been on an extraordinary
an extraordinary journey when we started
out we had no stars we had no power or
muscle we didn't have enough money
really to do what we wanted to do but
what we had was a script that inspired
mad love in everyone who read it we had
a genius for a director we had a cast
and a crew who were unwavering in their
commitment and whose talents are up on
the screen for all of you to see we had
partners in film four and Salladhor in
pathway and Fox Searchlight who had the
courage to support us and we had a
shared love for the extraordinary city
of Mumbai where we made the movie most
of all we had passion and we had belief
in our film shows that if you have those
two things truly anything is possible i
want to thank on a personal note my mum
and my dad for all their love and
support over the years i want to thank
my girl Saskia Mulder who's my partner
in crime and the light in my life and I
want to thank all of you very much
indeed thanks
[Applause]